welcome to tips to become 2,024 more Christian.
by the way,
these are my new nails for Christmas.
Number 1 is,
go to church services more often.
yes there will be many of you who don't like it that way,
but it is so important.
it may be that Catholic worship is good here,
that here theal service is fit,
that you'd rather go to a free church.
you really need to learn what kind of guy you are,
what kind of church you are.
Number 2 is your evening routine.
always incorporate some Bible reading.
that does not mean now,
that you now really 3 hours in the evening
have to read Bible every evening,
but alone 5 pages every night
to have so ne routine
is perfect and God will love you for it.
Number 3 is,
no longer judge and you now think really hard,
but it's not that hard.
I used to judge people really blatantly,
blasphemed and stuff,
but for a few weeks I have the feeling
I almost don't do that at all anymore
and believe me
it also does other people a favor.
if you want part 3,
feel free to follow me for more.